this video contains spoilers for
everything within the danganronpa
universe except for v3 if you haven't
played v3 than you're safe but be aware
that everything else is fair game enjoy
the video I'm not any kind of elite
anything hope isn't a talent you develop
but still I refuse to give up I refuse
to get bored and I refuse to throw it
all away that refused to despair because
all I have going for me is the desire to
keep moving forward hello and welcome to
danganronpa 101 the series that breaks
down everyone and everything in the
danganronpa world and stay we are going
to be examining one of our key
protagonist the ultimate hope himself
Makoto naegi Makoto naegi is a young boy
of average appearance intellect and
talent who can actually best be
described as an entirely ordinary person
however within the universe of
danganronpa being entirely ordinary is
actually quite extraordinary given the
wide range of exceptional personalities
on display as far as his history goes
makoto was born into a fairly nuclear
family with a loving mother and father
as well as a younger sister named komaru
and to give you an idea of just how
ordinary this family unit was well
typical life in the Naoki household
consisted of Makoto's mother watching
daytime talk shows Makoto and Kamara
discussing TV and manga and on Saturday
if Makoto's dad didn't have to work well
then he would not shave his beard
radical Einar in the sense of how shall
we put this mediocrity has gone on to
serve Makoto quite well actually
as it allows him to be a grounded
individual capable of great kindness and
empathy to those around him and in
addition to that whilst not immediately
apparent
Makoto does have one world-changing
special trait which is his unrelenting
sense of optimism and belief in the
concept of hope however with all of this
in mind Makoto would be selected to
become part of the 70th class of hopes
Peak Academy an institution designed to
identify and foster the talents of
exceptional students and even bestow
them with an ultimate title although in
Makoto's case he didn't actually do
anything to qualify for the academy and
his name was instead drawn from a
lottery and as a result he was dubbed as
the ultimate lucky student and luck is
something that Mikoto certainly
possesses in great quantities although
as with many of his finest features it
is not immediately apparent generally
makoto's luck will take on the form of
various unfortunate events that end up
working in his favor a very basic
example of which would be slipping on a
piece of paper to avoid being hit by a
rent
that was thrown at him thus having his
luck brought to him in the form of
misfortune in fact it was through a
series of wild misfortune that makoto
would come to be selected as the
ultimate lucky student and his streak of
absurdly quote/unquote bad luck led to a
series of events described in Makoto
naegi secret file that resulted in the
burning of an admission letter to a
student who was originally selected to
become the ultimate lucky student
however due to the headmaster of hopes
Peak Academy believing that this
misfortune was a sign that the original
student was not in fact lucky the
lottery was performed once again which
resulted in Makoto being chosen and soem
ACOTA became part of the seventieth
class of hopes Peak Academy and spent
roughly a year living and studying
happily with his classmates up until the
tragedy occurred during this world
shaking event Makoto and the rest of the
seventieth class was sealed inside of
hopes Peak Academy for their own
protection however little did they know
that the instigator of the tragedy and
the ultimate despair was one of their
very own classmates the ultimate despair
would then take away the memories of the
seventieth class and forced them to
participate in a killing game designed
to remove the last shred of hope from
the world and plunge it into pure
despair throughout this game and despite
his memory loss makoto would develop
close relationships with each of his
fellow students although a few in
particular deserve a mention firstly the
ultimate pop sensation sigh Akamai's
Ohno Makoto had known since middle
school and whom it was heavily implied
that he had a crush on however the two
graduated middle school without ever
having spoken to one another now truly
Makoto and Sokka gravitated towards each
other on the grounds of familiarity
during the game although this
relationship would be skewed by the
conditions of the game and shortly after
its commencement
Sayaka had planned to frame Makoto for
murder in order to escape herself a plan
which backfired heavily resulting in her
death Makoto would also come to develop
a surprising bond with the esteemed
beyond Kyoto gommi who spent much of
their time together with a greatly
antagonistic attitude towards Makoto but
eventually the two developed a strong
working relationship that remained far
beyond the killing game and finally we
have to mention Kyoko Kira Giri the
person who Makoto believes is
responsible for keeping him alive
despite the opposite very much also
being true in fact this is blatantly the
case when during a class trial where all
of the evidence was pointing towards
Kyoko Makoto refused to incriminate her
and was instead voted guilty of murder
and almost executed himself all because
of the pure trust that he had placed in
Kyoko towards the end of the killing
game there are even subtle hints that
the two had developed feelings for each
other which goes on to be somewhat
confirmed in the events following the
game however before we get there this
game entitled killer
school life would see the deaths of all
but six students of the 17th class
however the fact that even six of them
were able to survive can be attributed
to Makoto has no matter how deep the
despair became the coach's sense of hope
was so powerful that his true ultimate
talent would become apparent and he
would earn the label of the ultimate
hope this hope was enough to sustain the
other five survivors and after six class
trials they managed to defeat the
ultimate despair Junko Enoshima and
escaped into the outside world from here
most of the remainder of the 70th class
joined an organization known as the
Future Foundation which was dedicated to
fighting the rampant despair
apocalyptically spread throughout the
world by Junko in this effort the
foundation discovered the remnants of
despair which were a group of hopes Peak
Academy students from Junko corrupted
and used to set the world ablaze
however Mikoto being the shining ray of
hope he is decided to protect these
individuals and attempt to undo the harm
of Junko had done to them by placing
them into the new world program to
administer psychotherapy although the
program was infected by a virus
possessing an AI junker and the class
were forced into a digital version of
the killing game the Makoto and his
class had experienced in reality and at
one stage things became so dire for that
class that Makoto along with Kyoko and
byakuya entered the neo world program to
assist the remnants of despair in
defeating the AI Junko this would come
at quite the cost though as Makoto was
charged with treason for harboring the
remnants of despair and a trial was
arranged for him at a future foundation
facility live just in case someone out
there for some reason thought that the
killing games were over before they were
very wrong as this would become the site
of yet another killing game involving
key members of the Future Foundation as
well as Makoto himself and very notably
this game could have seen the end of
Makoto as he was eventually subject to
the suicide video however he was saved
from his despair hypnosis by Jews Osaka
Korra as with all previous games has
turned into a bloodbath
with only five survivors managing to
defeat a game designed to inflict
maximum despair however afterwards the
world would receive its first taste of
profound victory as the remnants of
despair saved by Makoto and now
completely reformed appeared to stop
Ryota meter eye from brainwashing the
world and several months after the
conclusion of this game
Makoto and the Future Foundation decided
to continue their mission who's
spreading herb throughout the world by
rebuilding hopes Peak Academy with
Makoto becoming its new headmaster some
more fun facts about makoto makoto is
one of only four characters in the
current diagram of the universe to have
survived more than one killing game with
the others being AOE Asahina Kyoko Kira
Giri and
hinata in both Japanese and English
Makoto she has a voice actor with Nagato
kameda one of the remnants of despair
featured in the events of danganronpa 2
however this is no accident as Nagato
was designed to be a darker parallel of
Makoto who was described by the
developers as a hope so extreme that it
became despair Makoto rather sadly is
the only character to retain his voice
actor from the game series in its anime
incarnation and finally a truly useless
fact the gas mask symbol on the back of
Makoto hoodie was a reference to a
previous game created by Spike Chunsoft
Lotus chunsoft as they were known at the
time entitled nine hours nine persons
nine doors but that pretty much does it
for Makoto naegi if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produced in general then please do
consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all the amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps plot
this channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
then please do head over to my discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
retakes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with who what
or where you'd like to see featured in
the next duncan romper 101
[Music]
[Music]